voici jamel debbouze
j'arrête je comprend un petit peu ses
applaudissements et cet accueil par ce
que j'ai lu cette semaine dans le figaro
entreprises que vous étiez l'acteur le
mieux payé de france devant gérard
depardieu je les lui aussi j'étais très
déçu par ce qui a été
ce qui a été marqué parce que c'est
complètement faux j'ai touché le triple
salve énerve que ce soit par e s qui m'a
amusé le plus c'est la manière dont ça a
été présenté son journal de france 2
parce qu'il disait à la grande surprise
générale bien sûr j'avoue qu'avant de
partir oui oui c'est un fait
j'ai trouvé ça j'ai trouvé ça amusant ça
nous fait plus de deux millions d'euros
c'est beaucoup
non
bonjour tu avais combien de jours de
tournage
six mois de tournage le mans mais en
même temps j'avais aucun problème quand
je touchais 3700 francs contre emploi
solidarité
j'ai aucun problème à toucher autant je
vois les uns autant d'argent aujourd'hui
je m'assieds du rmb lisf sans problème
je le répète super souple mais jamel en
plus ça part vite l'argent n'est plus
jean n'est plus là parce que mon frère
mon mot manquant pas ma cousine
d'audincourt mon frère de casa et ma
voisine du square le genre philippe ya
plus personne tu te reste combien sur
les 2 millions la madone restait 700
euros à l'état en tout et pour tout ça
va vite et pour les impôts t'as rien non
non ça c'est pas quand je me suis
arrangée avec pedro moi je les perds est
sûre si cette pige bien djamel alors
vous venez de came là où vous êtes une
star absolue d'ailleurs j'ai vu dans
paris match que vous étiez avec les plus
grandes stars du festival qui apprécie
beaucoup vu sur le pas vrai j'étais à
des amis de la weed
j'étais avec gt avec charles âgé tient
avec cas d'abdelkader raul
j'étais avec qu'il y avait d'autres on
éjecté qu'avec des cailleras du 7-8
c'est le seul starks connaître
alors un parc à loups passé beaucoup de
temps au maroc beaucoup de temps à
marrakech vous avez une maison jamel et
où vous avez monté des studios de cinéma
ouais ouais ouais on les a pas encore ça
fait monter puisqu'on n'a pas encore on
n'est pas encore arrivé dans la phase où
les studios sont en construction mais on
y arrive on y arrive très vite et
j'espère le chaland que dc dc prochain
festival du cinéma à marrakech on puisse
poser la première pierre
ouais ouais j'ai été super ce prix on
pour l'enterrer que de voir que j'avais
je n'avais pas d'à priori mais je ne
m'attendais pas à ce que les marocains
connaissent aussi bien le cinéma j'étais
vraiment surpris et de voir un premier
assistant parlait quatre langues
différentes gérer quatre mille personnes
je me suis dit mais j'ai vraiment vu ça
mais qui parle français anglais arabe
dans la même phrase ça donne
mais mais mais mais mais samassa massama
je me suis aperçu je le savais déjà mois
mais le maroc c'est pas comme c'est pas
culte et assuré qu'un paysage c'est
aussi des gens tu vois ce que dirait
qu'ils connaissent bien leur caf
donc ça me paraissait évident et logique
de montée des studios c'est une façon en
plus de faire du business et d'aider les
gens qui vivent là bas c'est vraiment
pas pour faire du business parce qu'un
studio finalement ça rapporte pas tant
d'argent que ça ça sent tout d'abord
beaucoup au départ mais moi ma démarche
première c'est vraiment d'essayer
d'amener de faire en sorte que les gens
de mon pays puisse travailler dans les
conditions les mieux possible les plus
normal puisque on monte d'abord a
vraiment aidé studio un centre national
de l'audiovisuel
ah ouais pour former les gens aux
problèmes métiers du cinéma et la
démarche a été en bon professionnel
d'après avant d'être financière c'est
bien moi j'essaye joël devos donc
au maroc à casablanca le vendredi 16 mai
cinq attentats suicide ont fait 48
victimes majorité de marocains plus
trois français deux espagnols un italien
pour en parler avec nous j'appelle
samira sitail
samira bonsoir donc vous êtes directrice
de l'information de la chaîne marocaine
2m
merci d'être avec nous djamel au maroc
j'imagine que c'est une star comme en
france qua non ah oui mais aussi connu
et même beaucoup plus connus je pense en
europe qu'ici puisque jamais elle c'est
la réussite
jamais elle c'est un symbole jamais elle
s'est pas uniquement la banlieue qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui il soit salué voir
décrit aussi par d'autres parce qu'ils
touchent le plus beau salaire de france
il
j'ai même si pato social au maroc gmail
cfoot à la fois et c'est une mégastar
bigot score d'entrée dans la gueule
maintenant j'ai amené mon avocat
donc en plein milieu des festivités
organisées à l'occasion de la naissance
le leem et du premier fils de mohammed
vi le roi du maroc et deux jours après
l'aïd al mawlid la fête de la naissance
du prophète
cinq attentats à la bombe ou la voiture
piégée visant essentiellement des
restaurants des hôtels fréquentés par
des étrangers ou lié à la communauté
juive ont eu lieu à casablanca
li membre des commandos kamikaze était
d'origine marocaine et ferait partie
d'un groupe islamiste appelait le droit
chemin
implanté dans la banlieue de casablanca
est rattachée plus ou moins à al qaïda
alors vous qui êtes directrice
d'information de l'important de chaînes
marocaines
que savez vous sur les coupables de
cette opération
d'abord ils sont tous marocains ce n'est
pas uniquement les huit en fait on a
identifié au jour d'aujourd'hui huit
cadavres sur les treize kamikazes qui se
sont donné la mort sur les différents
sites que vous avez décrit jeudi rossi
oui on a visé les symboles
on a visé des symboles qui font
qu'aujourd'hui le maroc est l'antithèse
la plus complète de ce que les radicaux
les intégristes défendent comme modèle
de société
nous leur faisons tous les jours la
démonstration de ce que le maroc peut
être un pays musulman profondément
attaché à ses racines profondément
musulman tout en étant un pays arabe
berbère juifs
d'une certaine manière puisque cette
religion fait partie de l'histoire du
maroc
donc ces marocains qui sont touchés
lorsqu'on pose une bombe devant
l'alliance juive c'est les marocains qui
sont touchés c'est pas les juifs les
musulmans c'est d'abord cela est un juif
persécuté dans ce pays c'est quelque
chose de nouveau c'est quelque chose de
nouveau pour nous comme le sont ces
attentats imaginez qu'une ville paisible
se réveille un matin dans l'horreur la
plus absolue avec j'ai pas une ré cela
aux téléspectateurs mais c'est vraiment
le loreur et moi j'ai eu un fils mais
tout ça j'ai eu à voir tout cela et j'ai
eu à faire des choix de ne pas montrer
le visage une tête un gamin qui dort
encore qui va s'éveiller avec les images
peut-être de son père la tête coupée à
la une de notre journal
j'ai refusé cela j'ai voulu respecter
cela je crois que tous les marocains
quelque part sont un peu comme moi
aujourd'hui ils ont cette attitude à la
fois de surprise à la fois de révolte de
colère et en même temps et c'est ça
peut-être si j'osais dire à toute chose
malheur est bon que nous retiendrons de
ce 16 mai qui était le jour de mon
anniversaire
nous retiendrons que nous sommes plus
forts et que notre modèle est le bon et
aussi que cette guerre antiterroriste
menée à l'échelle mondiale dans un
désordre absolu depuis 18 mois nous en
payons nous les marocains aujourd'hui
les pots cassés et que c'est un échec
absolu
ce qui est important de dire c'est que
ça arrive au moment où ou maroc
progresse vers une vraie démocratie où
on commença à s'inscrire vers le ce qui
m'a le plus étonné c'est que vraiment je
sais tu sais j'ai le sentiment que mon
pays mon pays a été touché au coeur et
et on est entre être presque parce que
j'ai j'ai j'avais le sentiment que mon
pays progressaient que 5,5 ça que ça se
développait qu'on allait qu'on allait
qu'on allait vers une vraie ouverture
sais pas comment t'expliquer mais je
j'ai été j'ai été outré mots pour non
pas parce que j'ai jamais connu ça au
maroc j'ai jamais vu ma mère dans cet
état là j'avais mon grand père ma
famille et je me suis aperçu que partout
dans le monde
aujourd'hui on est on est on est plus à
l'abri nulle part il ya vu mille morts
sur les routes
il ya ça a été touché new york a été
touché en plein coeur paris pareil à
vitrolles ya catherine mégret
on est à l'abri nulle part donc
franchement aujourd'hui j'ai le
sentiment qu'il faut continuer à vivre
sa vie comme on l'entend et comme on dit
dans ma cité knicks à mr le maire
il faut quand même espérer que c'est pas
ces événements dramatiques qui vont
faire changer le contraire vous savez
nous sommes à la veille d'une très
grosse manifestation dans les rues de
gaza
tout le monde descend demain tout le
maroc est dehors
demain juifs musulmans chrétiens vivant
dans ce pays puisque on en parle et
qu'il s'agit bien de cela nous défendons
cela c'est une partie de notre identité
nous combattrons l'intégrisme et si nous
n'étions pas conscient depuis un an
parce que c'est vrai on nous a dit il ya
des cellules dormantes
attention quand on a parlé samira quand
on a parlé des cellules dormantes
il ya beaucoup d'intellectuels et
certains journaux qu'on dit c'est une
manoeuvre du pouvoir en fait c'est
existe pas tout ça c'est pour aller vers
le plus sécuritaire et en fait c'était
vrai c'était vrai et depuis le 16 mai je
peux vous garantir que cette presse là
ces intellectuels là où ces gauchos
caviar qui hante la capitale économique
et rabat et qui ne finalement ne
connaissent pas très bien le maroc et
bien je peux vous dire qu'aujourd'hui
sont très mal à l'aise et qu'aujourd'hui
il s'agit pour nous de protéger ce que
nous sommes c'est notre patrimoine c'est
ce que nous sommes et le marché le plus
important c'est pour le maroc c'est la
france 55 % du flux touristique au maroc
c'est le marché français et au contraire
et c'est ça qui est extraordinaire et
c'est pour ça que je suis heureuse
d'être là en france et sur ce plateau de
télévision
parce que les français ont dit non avec
les marocains à ce terrorisme en disant
bas nous venons réservations dans les
maintient le maroc le maroc c'est aussi
un peu chez nous voilà
elvis gaza on avait compris les
réactions mohamed 6 s'est rendu
évidemment sur les lieux du drame
alors moi métier c'est le commandeur des
croyants ça veut dire qu il est
commandeur de tous les croyants c'est à
dire les juifs les chrétiens et les
musulmans
les trois religions eu droit religion il
est bien sûr musulman est la religion
majoritaire au maroc et nie slam mais il
est le protecteur comme le fut
d'ailleurs son grand-père et sa la
communauté juive séfarade le sait et
j'aurais toujours aimé me l'ont acclamé
de la côte et le regard de l'oci a dit
au roi mohamed 5 vous nous livrer les
juifs pour qu'ils puissent livrer aux
anneaux il a dit je ne voulais livrerait
pas s'ils sont sous ma protection
lorsque d'espagne on les a chassés
réprimer ils sont venus au maroc ils
vivent et je répète je ne sais pas si je
les exprime bien nous sommes obligés
bien comprendre bien le fait est que
c'est ça qu'on veut toucher et ce n'est
pas à nous uniquement de le défendre
nous du maroc nous paye arables
musulmans revendiquant cette identité
musulmane tout en projetant de comme
n'importe quel citoyen de ce monde
aujourd'hui
alors moi médecis est en train de
démocratiser le maroc mais effectivement
plus de liberté c'est plus de liberté
pour les idées toutes les idées même les
idées islamistes c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui au maroc il ya des
journaux quand même très radicaux qui
paraissent aujourd'hui et depuis le 16
mai les marocains je crois qu'ils se
sont rendus compte que c'était tous
pareils que c'est les moyens qui change
il ya ceux qui prônent la violence et
ceux qui prônent cette autre violence
encore plus terrible et meurtrière à la
une de leurs fourneaux pour les
marocains c'est tous pareils il faut les
combattre et nous les combattrons et ça
ne passera pas quelle a été la réaction
du parti de la justice et du
développement qui est un parti
islamique qui est reconnue et qui
participent à la vie démocratique du
maroc
bien sûr qu'ils les en témoignent les
ans condamné mais lorsque leurs
responsables à la une de cette prison où
parlait tout à l'heure
font l'apologie de ces groupuscules
radicaux qui aujourd'hui agissent sur le
terrain ils sont tout aussi responsables
que c'est treize kamikazes qui sont
marocains des jeunes qui se sont fait
encadrer manipulés par des personnes qui
auraient pu être celle du pjd
mais le pjd a condamné les attentats et
pourquoi leur intervention n'a pas été
retransmise de la télévision marocaine
sur tvm je ne suis pas la tvm je suis
deuxième l'autre social de télévision
mais le fait est que vous n'allez pas
dans un moment comme celui ci où les
partis politiques progressistes de ce
pays et sont nombreux les rejettent leur
dise non faites votre manif tout seul on
la fera pas avec vous on fera la mode de
notre côté bon il est tout à fait la
réaction est tout à fait normal ou et
moi je le dis et je le revendique
je refuse comme ça a été le cas moi ça
tombe de responsables de la presse
française un moment donné qu'ils ont
décidé officieusement de banaliser leurs
discours leurs appels au meurtre
ce n'est pas cela la démocratie ce n'est
pas cela le maroc que moi je voudrais
sur ce que vous proposez finalement
c'est qu'on considère au maroc
le pjd comme en france le front national
est considéré c'est à dire qu'il n'est
pas admis en fait dans le jeu médiatique
votre comparaison est un peu caricatural
mais je vous dirais une chose elle me
convient tout à fait et je crois que si
vous me posiez la question de savoir
pourquoi tout d'un coup ils ont 38
députés au parlement je vous dirais
qu'on n'a pas vu venir la vague qui a
été celle de le pen
l'année dernière mais je passerai sur
les détails je dirais que la comparaison
n'est pas malvenu
joël vous avez des copains qui sont
tentés par l'islamisme maroc ou en
france malheureusement
malheureusement dans nos quartiers
souvent les maîtres de mon quartier sont
pas respectés et un terroriste c'est
quoi enfin j'ai pas la définition mais
je pense que c'est d'abord a frustré
c'est la convainc pas tout cas qu'on
rejette quelqu'un qu'on méprise est
profondément meurtri je crois pour
pouvoir la bella et je sais que ça
t'amène de mon quartier mais facilement
ferranderie cadets et se retrouve dans
des histoires bizarres parce qu'on n'est
calcule pas si on les écoute pas parce
qu'on est on les rejette en bloc et si
j'ai réussi à m'en sortir aujourd'hui
sans prendre parce qu'on pense parce
qu'à un moment donné on m'a dit tu es un
mec bien continuer fonce et et c'est
devant ce discours là que j'ai eu envie
de faire mieux et dans fear 2 d'essayer
de mieux que je peux de décevoir
personne
mais c'est sûr que que nous en tout cas
dans leurs bottes dans le banlieue comme
comme je le répète souvent et on en zone
d'éducation prioritaire si on est en
zone d'urbanisme 70 organisations
priorité quand on est quand on monte des
commerçants en zones franches falaises
appel léonard ce que je veux dire c'est
difficile et c'est sûr que quand on
trouve le réconfort dans une mosquée
enfin moi je comprends pas mais je les
jeunes explique en tout cas cessé des
mots c'est de voir un mec qui dit tu es
un mec bien continue lâche pas un doigt
pendant qu'elle 2010 dans quel secteur
d'activité dévolu ça fait c'est toujours
ça fait toujours plaisir
c'est vrai qu au maroc le succès des
islamistes radicaux c'est plus que leurs
prêches encore c'est la façon qu'ils ont
de s'occuper des gens ses accents soul
terrain ils ont des actions de
solidarité des actions caritatives
il ya que le pjd cas un vrai projet de
société on se demande si les autres
partis politiques qui sont en danger
démocratique au maroc ont des projets de
société aussi défini que pjd ça c'est
faux ces fautes chéri
ces fossés véhicule est effectivement
passé nombre de publications celles dont
vous parliez tout à l'heure il y en a
plusieurs y en a deux ou trois et c'est
aussi ce que les médias occidentaux
souhaitent retenir
vous le savez très bien on ne parle
jamais des trains qui arrivent à l'heure
on ne parle que de ceux qui sont en
retard c'est une très belle image
samira lâche pas le morceau tout le tien
le pjd est un train qui malheureusement
arrivent en retard d'entente dont je n
aurai la note juste juste un moyen qui
va s'étendre non attendez akon a comme
ça mais non c'est à elle de parler de
jackson hole a laissé tranquille il faut
pas l'énerver
mais c'est vrai enfin ils n'ont pas de
projet de société ils n'ont pas de
revendications ils n'ont pas des
messages vous savez et joue un peu sur
cette fibre arabo-musulmane attention et
nous les arabes les l'identité etc
il joue sur cette fibre on en profite
très franchement pour mon pays c'est la
première fois c'est pour ça que j'étais
choqué jeudi en début d'émission que ça
m'avait c'est bon sens et fait mal au
coeur de voir dans cet état là mais mais
mais c'est bien sûr que c'est grave mais
encore une fois plus personne n'est à
l'abri donc on n'en parle aujourd'hui
moi vraiment sur le coup j'étais très
choquée et puis finalement je me suis
dit c'est la vie je vais pas m'arrêter
de vivre pour je vais pas m'arrêter de
continuer à aa les noms n'est pas que
c'est cesser si le début pour moi
presque n'en est pas qu ici pas de la
résistance c'est le début de l'ajout et
je peux appeler ça comme tu veux m'aimer
mais c'est le début
c'est le début parce que aujourd'hui je
crois en mon pays c'est payant quelqu'un
qui est plein de promesses stade ya
goûté un attaché de marque full par
exemple comment sa déchirante âge et
leur foi
oui c'est mon premier voyage à
l'étranger et au maroc quand j'avais 16
ans alors franchement si vous prive et
agile mort foule
puisse allah à cause de terroristes vous
êtes tous marocains et couscous tunisien
alors là ya du poisson la même et tu
vois juste n'avions que je voulais pour
éviter de 2 il s'est passé il ya pas
longtemps il faut c'est terrible en
algérie et un tremblement de terre ça a
fait 500 morts des milliers de blessés
on n'a pas de pot bordel de merde c'est
ça qui est en train de me dire on n'a
pas de pot et puis moi j'ai envie
d'adresser un message d'espoir à tous
ces algériens à tous ces marocains qui
souffrent à tous ces musulmans qui ont
regardé très regardée au maghreb qui qui
qui qui sont qui sont dans le lot dans
le noir il faut il ya trop de cons se
dit tout haut ou cécile anne boulay tu
sais enfin à la fin de chaque phrase
tabulaire tout va bien et j'ai envie de
leur dire les algues mais on est encore
là
nous arrêterons pas c'est pas possible
la jolie quand on termine en disant un
mot au sujet du roi du maroc qui
regardent souvent tout le monde en parle
est ce que est ce que vous pensez qu'il
va tenir bon face à face à ça il faut
juste peut-être dire que quand on dit
modery radical machette et terra le roi
commandeur des croyants et il n'est pas
le représentant d'un islam modéré
il est le représentant de l'islam picot
le ceux qui connaissent les livres qui
connaissent le courant et je vous invite
à le faire si vous ne connaissez pas ce
n'est pas cette haine qui se déversent
tous les jours en ce moment c'est cesser
de l'amour c'est de la tolérance et
beaucoup de vérité commande qu'on
donnerait les attentats bien sûr bien
sûr
alors lorsqu'on en brigade ces pauvres
gamins et que l'on dit vas-y tu ira au
paradis
eh bien on leur ment on leur dit que
même les femmes qui les attend et là ça
quand même
en même temps un vois moi franchement je
plonge vraiment le terroriste femmes
c'est pas mal on a fait quelques mines
merci
exceptionnel
alors on va au maroc une femme peut être
directrice de l'information d'une chaîne
de télévision
ouais elle tout ce que ça implique au
maroc et c'est pas l'eau dans tu vois
c'est une meuf que j'adore ella ella
ella beaucoup de courage et beaucoup de
charisme
samira si tu aimes écoutes je te kiffe